>>Student: More and more
people are coming out.
And then more and more people are
becoming accepting of LGBT rights.
>>Soljane: If you are
personally connected to an issue,
might that make it harder or easier
for you to go to that other side?
>>Student: If you have been affected by
an issue and it's like really, really--
that made you who you are
today, I think it's really hard
to change your views on that.
>>Pedro: I think this
class has brung all
of the seniors together a little more.
It just taught us a lot in how
to get along with each other
and how to agree to disagree.
>>Jessica: At Highlander,
we want students to be able
to look at something critically.
They need to know how to advocate
for themselves, but they also know
that they have to take
in various perspectives.
>>Soljane: Our students come with
these very firm ideas and beliefs
about certain topics, because it's
the only perspective they've known.
So, I really like to push
the envelope with them.
>>Soljane: We're going to revisit
today some of those really tough issues
that we've looked at this year.
>>Soljane: We've covered
things like abortion,
sexual assault on college campuses,
immigration, presidential appointments.
So, as the news has been happening
and our country's been
evolving, that's what we cover.
>>Alex: Today's class the main focus
was to see others' perspective.
That's a recurring problem in the
United States where we are too divided
and we don't listen to the other side.
>>Soljane: You know, it's really
an important skill for you to have,
looking at things from the point of view
of someone who has a different opinion.
It's not a wrong versus right.
It's a "Well, you know, what?
Let me take a step over to your side."
>>Pedro: Prior to this I honestly wasn't
interested at all in any current events.
I could care less about
the news or anything,
but ever since this class
it made me more aware of,
like, what's going on around me.
>>Soljane: How many of
you are thinking you'd
like to revisit community police divide?
Poverty blame game?
And the LGBT debate?
So, you'll have ten minutes to review
any of the resources for your topic.
>>Pedro: First, we learned
background information.
>>Pedro: Blacks are twenty-four-point
one percent-- that's the poverty rate.
And Hispanics are twenty-one-point five.
>>Alex: And mostly we have
discussions to see where we stand
and we share our ideas and opinions.
>>Student: I put that
it's not their fault.
It's how they grew up.
>>Pedro: And we kind of debate and try
and play devil's advocate
for both sides.
>>Pedro: I don't agree with that,
because there's a bunch of Hispanics
that are not poor and they chose
to make the change in their life
to get them out of the poverty.
>>Student: For a long time, LGBT groups
have been attacked by religious groups.
I think there has been a lot of
laws that, like, discriminate.
Like, because you're a trans, don't go
use that-- the bathroom that, you know--
>>Kadeem: I'm from a
very homophobic country.
LGBT persons are usually
being discriminated against.
So, now I see the need to fit myself
in their shoe and also accept them.
>>Soljane: I wanted to take a few
minutes to maybe debrief this process.
What was this like for you?
Where is another place you might
potentially be able to apply this?
>>Alex: I believe that we can apply
this in the real world right now,
because in America I feel like we pretty
much block what we think is wrong.
>>Alex: What I have learned in class
has prepared me to talk to new people
and maybe people that I disagree with.
Maybe you can educate them, maybe
you can do your research and see
if what they're saying is right.
>>Soljane: I just really
want them to have, like,
a tool belt when they
go into the real world.
>>Soljane: The fact that you were
at least willing to step outside
of your comfort zone and
listen and acknowledge people--
>>Soljane: It's all about your
ability to present yourself in a way
that people will be receptive to what
you want to say, even if it's something
that they don't agree with.
>>Pedro: If you learned how
to argue your point and listen
to another person's point without
completely shutting them out,
you can get where that
person is coming from.
That's what makes us the strongest.